you've been convicted of the murder of
Margaret Barnes the circumstances of the
case were very unusual
for a few days in early July 2022 Mrs
Barnes was visiting barmouth she came
there alone although it seems that she
saw some friends or acquaintances during
her visit
in the course of Sunday the 10th of July
2022 she was thinking about where to
stay that night
it seems that someone made an
arrangement for her to stay at the
Wavecrest BNB a few doors away from your
house in Marine parade
we know that in the late afternoon early
and early evening she was walking in
barmouth she bought some food and drink
the evidence suggests that she was
significantly under the influence of
alcohol at 10 past 10 pm she approached
your house the only suggested
explanation for this is that she mistook
your house for the BNB where she had a
booking the door was unlocked and she
went in it seems that meeting nobody in
the front hall she went upstairs and
installed herself in what was in fact
your bedroom
at that time you and your partner were
in another room in the house watching
television in the course of the day
you'd had quite a substantial amount to
drink
at about 10 45 PM you and your partner
decided to go to bed you found your
bedroom locked from the inside you got a
spare key and when the two of you
entered the room you were astonished to
find Mrs Barnes in the bed holding a
drink in her hand possessions scattered
around with a smell of cigarette smoke
it seemed to you that she had tampered
with some of your possessions too
your first reaction was entirely
appropriate you asked her what she was
doing in your home you've said that her
replies were contradictory or confused
at 10 52 PM you telephone the police
told them calmly about the situation and
asked them to send someone to remove Mrs
Barnes
but after that things went terribly
wrong
you rejoined your partner in Mrs Barnes
in the bedroom there was some sort of
Confrontation when told that the police
had been called you've said that Mrs
Barnes responded aggressively and she
accused your partner of stealing her
handbag and lunged towards her
it seems that this was the trigger for
what happened next
the jury has found that you assaulted
Mrs Barnes with a kick or a stamp that
kick or stamp must have been inflicted
with considerable thoughts the evidence
of a pathologist told us that Mrs Barnes
sustained a catastrophic injury
including three broken ribs and an
injury to her liver which in the opinion
of the pathologist was unsurvivable
that's the crime of which you've been
convicted
immediately afterwards you drag Mrs
Barnes by her ankles down the stairs to
the ground floor you then flung her
wheeled suitcase out into the front yard
your partner then LED Mrs Barnes outside
supporting her by her arm we've seen
that on CCTV it's clear that your
partner acted gently and carefully in
her contact with this 71 year old lady
who at that time was unsteady on her
feet
who then came outside and your behavior
towards Mrs Barnes was aggressive and
offensive you sat on an outside chair
and watched her in an aggressive or
threatening attitude while she crouched
on the ground trying to gather her
possessions together
within her ear shoulders she crouched or
lay on the ground you accused her of
stealing and deliver
I'm glad to say that in your evidence to
the court you acknowledge that appalling
behavior and apologized for it
over the next couple of hours Mrs Barnes
remained on the ground outside your
house and her condition deteriorated
the police did not attend because they'd
been diverted to a Firearms incident
nearby no ambulance was able to attend
until it was too late though as I've
said medical treatment would not have
saved her
during that time you remained present as
did some of the neighbors and for much
of the time your partner
your partner and two of The Neighbors in
particular behaved appropriately they
could see Mrs bonds was in trouble they
stayed by her tended her as best they
could and tried to summon assistance at
least she received Compassionate Care
from them during her last hours
your behavior however remained
inappropriate and insulting when a
neighbor asked you to call an ambulance
you refused so the neighbor called the
ambulance herself you did bring some
cushions to Mrs Barnes in a drink of
water and on one occasion take her pulse
when asked to do so and I've not
overlooked those matters of detail
by about 1am Mrs Barnes was being given
CPR by a neighbor at about 2 A.M after
Emergency Services had arrived she was
declared dead
the jury has found that she was killed
by the kick or stamp which you delivered
with the intention of doing her really
serious physical harm
now I accept that you must have been
very shocked to find a stranger in your
house in your bedroom
I also work on the assumption that she
behaved aggressively towards your
partner accusing her of stealing and
lunging towards her
but your reactions surpassed anything
that any reasonable person could imagine
you're a large and strong man aged 45 at
the time
she was small and slight at least 25
years older than you and clearly
affected by alcohol and unsteady on her
feet
I can understand why you might have
escorted her out of your house though a
different person might have responded to
this situation by trying to help her
but the assault a kick or stamp of
sufficient Force to cause a fatal injury
was a Dreadful thing to do to a
defenseless elderly person
we've heard moving Victim Impact
statements from members of Mrs barnes's
family for whom her loss has been
devastating
she was a much-loved wife mother and
grandmother
by Statute the sentence for murder is
life imprisonment my task is to
determine the minimum term which you
must serve before you can be considered
for release
then determining the minimum term I'm
mistake into account the seriousness of
the offense and must give credit for any
periods of remand in custody
I have to have regard to the principles
set out in schedule 21 to the sentencing
Act 2020.
applying those principles this is not
the sort of wholly exceptional case
which attracts a whole life term under
paragraph two nor is it in the
categories which attract minimum terms
of 25 or 30 years under paragraphs three
and four
that being so paragraph 5 provides that
for an adult offender the appropriate
starting point for the minimum term is
15 years
I'm then required to take into account
any aggravating or mitigating factors
which have not already been considered
in my choice of starting point
schedule 21 provides non-exhaustive
lists of factors which may be relevant
in this case two statutory aggravating
factors were present first the fact that
the victim was particularly vulnerable
because of age or disability as I've
said Margaret Barnes was a frail and
elderly lady affected by intoxication
second mental or physical suffering
inflicted on the victim before death
as I've said you forcefully dragged her
down the stairs and then outside the
house you engaged in the insulting and
taunting behavior that I've described
those matters did not contribute to her
death but they make the case more
serious
there were also other aggravating
factors not specified in the legislation
such as refusing to call an ambulance
though the only effect of that was that
it was called by a neighbor instead the
use of a short foot as a weapon and
committing the offense under the
influence of alcohol
although I do not find that alcohol was
a significant factor
also present were two statutory
mitigating factors
first I find that in this case your
intention was to cause really serious
bodily harm rather than to kill
second a lack of premeditation
your encounter with Mrs Barnes was as
I've made clear utterly unexpected
it seems clear that the confrontation
between her and you and your partner and
your assault on her happened suddenly
there are some other mitigating factors
as well
third the fact that this crime followed
hard upon the shock of finding a
stranger in your home and this was at a
time when you were under personal stress
as a result of a medical condition which
had caused your driving license to be
removed or suspended causing isolation
and difficulties for you
forth the fact that the Fatal assault
consisted only of a single blow
finally it's important to note that
until that day last July you were of
good character with no convictions
cautions or reprimands recorded against
you having reached the age of 46.
I have read numerous character
references which show that you have been
a hard-working and community-minded
person with many people having
experienced kindness and generosity from
you
your Council has put forward some other
factors for my consideration but these
have not made a material difference
I do not accept your good character
extended to what the courts sometimes
call exemplary conduct
the impact of this case on your family
must be considerable but that is an
almost inevitable consequence of an
offense of this kind your positive
attitude to custody is to your credit
but is not so unusual as to affect the
minimum term
and I'm not in a position to judge that
the risk which you may pose in the
future is necessarily particularly low
as Council has suggested
and nor can I interpret any of your
remarks made at the scene as an
acceptance of culpability which could
make a significant difference to
sentence bearing in mind you're not
guilty plea to the charges that you
faced
the aggravating factors on the one hand
and the mitigating factors on the other
both carry significant weight they're
close to canceling each other out
nevertheless I attach a particular
weight to the lack of intention to kill
and to the sudden and bizarre
circumstances in which your
unpremeditated offense was committed
those things do not begin to excuse what
you did
they do however differentiate this case
from many others to which the same
15-year starting point would apply
the net effect is that I will make a
small downward adjustment to the minimum
term to 14 years
can you stand up please Mr Redfern
the sentence for murder is life
imprisonment
the minimum term will be 14 years
the time which you've spent on ramam's
238 days will be deducted from the time
you must now serve making a net minimum
term of 13 years and 127 days if that
figure is wrong for any reason it can be
corrected administratively it's
important that you and everyone involved
with this case should understand what
this means the minimum term is not a
fixed term after which you'll be
automatically released it's the minimum
time you'll spend in custody in full
before your case can be considered by
the parole board
it will be for them to say whether and
if so on what conditions you're to be
released
if and when you are released you'll be
subject to license for the rest of your
life if you were to breach any condition
of a license the license could be
revoked and you would be recalled to
prison
and if the surcharge applies an order
will be drawn up accordingly
that concludes my sentence